it is time for drew's news the only news
that feels like finding a four-leaf
clover every day hopefully and with me
at the desk a little shamrock
hi everybody
day
and saint patrick's day so
i guess i can't pinch you rossi because
you're wearing green i am wearing green
and look i have a beard
i haven't had a beard since high school
she was a sweet girl
i bet she was rossi look at that hi
everybody
happy st patrick's day everyone now 54
of adults are celebrating today and
rossi guess economically speaking how
much money people are spending on this
holiday i have no idea hold on to your
leprechaun hat rossi because martha
stewart magazine reports that people
will spend 5.87
billion dollars what what so i'm like
what it's a lot of you know alcohol and
shamrock shakes and bar business and
listen this is good for the economy yeah
the average person will spend about 42
bucks on everything from green clothes
to corned beef and green beer so hey
happy st patrick's day and happy boost
to the economy well yeah i think when
it's ice cream
5.7 billion seems like a lot but when
you break it down like 42 yeah like i
bought this green shirt i didn't have a
green shirt but i knew i wanted to wear
a green shirt you know i love the color
of that green it's got a lot of blue and
it's very attractive thank you thank you
all right hey next up
anyone here watch fleabag we all with
phoebe wallerbridge
well
if you love that show great news
hollywood reporter says amazon just
greenlit greenlit on st patrick's day
greenland her next series details are
under wraps a little bit but it shoots
later this year and remember fleabag
premiered on amazon way back in 2016 and
it cleaned up at the emmys it won six of
them and since then phoebe has been
super busy she launched killing eve
which i'm obsessed with with sandra oh
she wrote the latest bond movie and now
she starts opposite harrison ford in
indiana jones 5.
i know i know and she has a brand new
project coming she really is the cat's
pajamas yes she is i cannot wait to see
this show i need phoebe waller bridge
i'm on the feeder hurry hurry hurry yeah
yeah uh-huh i could i i started it
and then i
just watched too much 90 day fiance it's
like everything else just gets back seat
do yourself a favor rossie and get on
the flea bag thing god it's just so good
okay i'm sold
[Music]